if I divide this line into two pieces
that are all equally that are both hot
plants or fires divided up like this
okay so this is I have to bind up the
line interval into two objects that are
half the size two objects that are half
the size
okay does that make sense I in exactly
the same way I don't I could divide it
into smaller pieces if I like I could go
thirds so I've got three objects sighs
okay now that's like yeah well what's
the big deal okay well let me move up
this is the Y let's consider a
two-dimensional object how about a
square that's a pretty print essentially
two-dimensional objects right so it
consider a square something different
happens here okay so if I draw myself a
square he is one now if I go I want a
square that's like a half sized square
okay a half size because it's got two
dimensions right if all of the
dimensions here are half all the
dimensions here are hard right so if
this was like you know ten units long
this would be five five five five okay I
don't have two objects or two components
that are half the size anymore do I
how many do I have I have four objects
four objects
now keep in mind right I'm using the
word size I don't mean area right
because these are not half the area they
have the size by which I mean each of
the dimensions length and width have
been halved okay so I've got four
objects that
besides okay for Rogers now you can see
what happens if I apply this similar
logic up here right if I divide it into
objects that are a third this size how
many of them are gonna get it gonna get
I'm gonna get nine of them right this is
gonna be okay nine objects that are a
third the size okay
we're gonna do one more time right one
dimension two dimensions three
dimensions all right consider a cube
this is gonna get a little tricky to
draw that's okay right so he's a cube
now it's got three dimensions length
width and height so if I have all of
them if I have all of them
how many component pieces am I going to
get on the frontier right on the
frontier
be careful I'm going to start drawing it
maybe you'll see what happens right I'm
going to get little cubes
okay have a look at this what my drawing
I've only drawn a half of the cube have
entire my can you see this is like as it
were the front half let me get another
color so you can see how much of the
cube I at all I've drawn this part here
that's in front of the red okay the
reason why it's half is because all of
my dimensions have been halved right so
per is this the width of my new swear
thank you my little one is exactly half
the width of my original cube right
excuse me the height of each of my new
tubes is exactly half the height of my
original cube and therefore my depth
here is exactly half of the original
death okay so that means if that's how I
need to do the rest of them is another
for hiding behind do you see that
okay can you see them hiding there right
it's not too bad so what I'm like how
many cubes come up for the front for the
back I've eight right I have eight
objects the size of the original cubes
okay I've got eight of them now I
promise I won't make you draw the next
one because I don't know I have enough
trouble drawing this one okay you can
guess though you can calculate look at
the pattern here you don't need to draw
this next one to know how many little
cubes there will be if I make them the
size how many are you anticipating it's
gonna be 27 oh right because putting it
this way you can have nine on the front
and then nine in the middle and then
nine at the back that's 27 27 okay
that's enough examples where do
dimensions come into play right we're
gonna do it in reverse this is a three
dimensional kind of object right three
dimensional so you notice see these two
numbers here these numbers are not
coincidental or random right what kinds
of numbers are they their cubic numbers
right in fact this is too cute and this
is why is this 1 2 and this 1 3 why is
that
very good this 2 corresponds to this
Huff you see that and this 3 corresponds
to disturb you with me okay reverse we
had 4 and then 9
so one of those numbers they're not
really for a nine they are square
numbers square numbers this is three
squared W three sweat and the three
corresponds just like before to the
third what's this guy two squared and
the two corresponds to the half okay
this one is a bit play because he's
one-dimensional right two and three are
really to the power of one and three the
power so if you could take a four
dimensional objects if you could imagine
it and divide it up into a bunch of
other four dimensional objects that will
all half the size how many would you
expect to get out you'd expect sixteen
smaller half sized four dimensional
objects okay all right now this is a
totally different way of thinking about
dimensions right that it's about
splitting the objects and seeing how
many you get versus the size